and it's the so that's what I'm saying
is is that I'm analyzing my behaviors
like at that time and I talked to my
therapist today about the time in the
movie theater with when we watch
hereditary you would see that was no no
what we did was wrong what what happened
quick breakdown yeah okay I'll give you
a quick synopsis we did watch a
hereditary and during when that girl's
head comes off you're jerking off so
there's a couple in front of us during
the end of the movie there was a
particularly scary scene and we screamed
yeah Bobby's coping mechanism when he
screams after he screams he this is
giggle at the end oh sure he screams and
he goes um the couple in front of us
didn't like that we were being
aggressive and or screaming at all
actually and they turned around and they
were like shut the [ __ ] up whoa and
basically yeah and basically told us if
you know that you make sounds at a movie
theater or like our you know scream you
probably shouldn't be watching this in
public
is what they told us oh but during a
scary part rooms a jump scare you left
their race out now I'm curious but uh
that's crazy to say an hereditary of all
things
that's insane turn around I've been like
shut the [ __ ] are you a stand-up
comedian I recognize you see that he's a
stand-up right well anyway instead of
just letting by his album and obviously
these people were like unreasonable sure
but we played their games right lights
came back up we waited for the crate way
down they waited yeah everyone left the
theater you waited till the end of the
credits yeah we wanted to see them in
the face I wanted to be like who the
[ __ ] are you we wanted to have a
confrontation because typically we're
really spineless sure we're the most
spineless couple ever when things are
done to was real okay well that didn't
work
so what well yeah what happened it
became a screaming one way screaming I
took my earrings off I slept Vaseline in
my lips I was ready to fight wait
literally yeah Filipinos for Manny this
one's for Pacquiao so uh there's four
stories to this hall where this theater
is down the escalator we're right behind
them screaming well they were screaming
right back though yeah screaming at each
other
oh I relate to this so much and then you
know what they did afterwards they were
like we need to call security
as if so they were white I figured it
out got it got it got it and then she
started and then the woman started
screaming but she started to get
emotional Wow then I doubled down
because then I got a little bit with and
it was like Blair high school all over
you loved it yeah and I hadn't popped
off like that
as an adult ever and but it was you but
I was [ __ ] up we just let it pass we
should have moved seeds they were crazy
yeah I do that too I literally I was
talking about this just with my family
on the way here before I've just before
I came here about the space between
incident and reaction the like that one
second space were like I was I was
talking about this fight I got into a
Burning Man recent this last year where
it's just like some guy was telling me
to move the but my bike and I was like
okay no problem and he's like because
they're out in the [ __ ] road and then
I was like and now I'm thinking back on
it
it actually ended very funny because
then I was just like they're not we
started getting in each other's faces or
screaming except burning us or a hippie
festival and I'm like you know step out
my face [ __ ] and then and then
just getting more and more tense and
then finally somebody grabs the guy and
pulls him away and grabs me and pulls me
what really did happen Wow somebody came
up to me and goes
hey are you Moshe kasher do you do a
podcast with Natasha it's like the worst
yeah I have the best coz it shows the
guy no he was long gone I just grabbed
the guys grab the guys sleeve ago please
don't tell anybody about this is there a
part of you though that where it's like
it's obviously not our job to teach
people how to have manners or how to
react but there's a part of me where I'm
like am I gonna let this guy live his
whole life unchecked does he do this to
other people well I've thought about
this a lot which is that sometime okay
as you live in the world and there's a
certain philosophy the where people like
like to fight because they go if you
live in the world and you're primate and
you get in the space of another primate
you're going to get the consequences of
a primate I'm my primary brain is going
to come up and I'm going to attack you